okay another absurd question about
intelligent life because uh you know
you're
you're an incredible programmer outside
of everything else we'll talk about just
as a programmer
uh do you think intelligent beings out
there the civilizations that were out
there
had computers and programming
did they do we naturally have to develop
something where we
engineer machines and are able to encode
both
knowledge into those machines and
instructions that
process that knowledge process that
information to to make decisions and
actions and so on
and with those programming languages if
you think they exist
be at all similar to anything we've
developed
so i don't see that much of a difference
between
quote unquote natural languages and
programming languages
um yeah i think there's so many
similarities so
when asked the question uh what do alien
languages look like
i imagine they're not all that
dissimilar from
ours and i think translating in and out
of them
uh wouldn't be that crazy well it's
difficult to compile
like dna to python and then to see
i mean there is a little bit of a gap in
in the kind of languages we use for
for uh touring machines and the kind of
languages
nature seems to use a little bit maybe
that's just
we just haven't cr we haven't understood
the kind of language that nature uses
well
yet dna is a cad model
it's not quite a programming language it
has no sort of
uh serial uh execution it's not
quite a uh yeah it's a cad model
um so i think in that sense we actually
completely understand it the problem is
um you know uh well simulating on these
cad models
i played with it a bit this year is
super uh computationally intensive
if you want to go down to like the
molecular level um where you need to go
to see a lot of these phenomena like
protein folding
um so yeah it's not that it's it's not
it's not that we don't understand it it
just requires a whole lot of compute to
kind of compile it
our human minds it's inefficient both
for the pro for the data representation
and for the programming yeah
it runs well on raw nature it runs well
in raw nature and when we try to build
uh emulators or simulators for that
uh well they're mad slow and i've tried
it
it runs in that yeah you've commented
elsewhere
i don't remember where that uh
one of the problems is simulating nature
is tough
and if you want to sort of deploy a
prototype
i forgot how you you put it but it made
me laugh but animals or humans would
need to be involved
in order to in order to try to run
some prototype code on um
like if we're talking about covid and
viruses and so on yeah
if you were trying to engineer some kind
of defense mechanisms
like a vaccine uh against coven or all
that kind of stuff
that doing any kind of experimentation
like you can with like autonomous
vehicles would be very
technically cost technically and
ethically costly
i'm not sure about that i think you can
do tons of uh
crazy biology and test tubes i think my
bigger complaint
is more all the tools are so bad
like literally you mean like like i'm
not libraries and
i'm not pipetting [ __ ] like you're
handing me a i gotta
no no no no there has to be some
like automating stuff and like the
yeah but human biology is messy like it
seems like
look at those dorano's videos they were
a joke it's like it's like a little
gantry it's like little xy
gantry high school science project with
the pipette i'm like
really got to be something better you
can't build like nice microfluidics and
i can program
the you know computation to biointerface
i mean this is going to happen
but like right now if you are asking me
to pipette
50 milliliters of solution amount
this is so crude
you